Benchmarks are very important to computer manufacturers. So usually there
are standard organizations that put together benchmarks suites for use in
comparing performance between machines. So usually there is a benchmarking
organization that takes input from manufacturers assistants, from user groups,
from experts in academia, and so on, and produces a standard benchmark suite,
along with instructions on how to produce representative measurements. So
this is how we got TPC benchmarks, which are used for databases, web servers,
data mining, and other transaction processing, so called EEMBC benchmarks, which
are used in embedded processing, such as cars, video players, printers, phones,
etc. So if we're testing a processor for, for example, potential use in a car,
we would use the EEMBC benchmarks, not the TPC. And the SPEC benchmarks,
which are typically used to evaluate engineering workstations and
also raw processors because these benchmarks, unlike the other two, are not very
IO-intensive. They're mostly processor oriented. So the SPEC benchmark suite
includes a number of applications, such as GCC, which represents software
development workloads like the compiler, several applications like BWAVES and
LBM that are representative fluid dynamics workloads,
PERL which is representative of string processing applications, CACTUS ADM,
this is a physics simulation related to relativity. This is a parser for XML.
Several solvers of differential equations. BZIP, a compression application. To
game ai applications, and so on. As you can see the spec bench are really trying
to cover a variety of potential users for processors in high performance systems